As soon as one thinks about letting multiple users access
a file system, it becomes clear that we will need
some notion of access rights. Looking at our directory tree
here again, it should be clear that Alice should not be
able to see guest's or Bob's file unless they say
it's okay. And we certainly don't want to let just any
user access the operating systems files. Ultimately, for each user
file pair, we need to know what permissions that user has.
That is, which of the basic actions of reading, writing,
and executing the file is he allowed to do? Conceptually, we
can think of this as a giant matrix with users
for the columns and files as the rows, for instance. And
we could store the information that way, but it would
be pretty inefficient. Think about how many files would have the
exact same set of values. UNIX like operating systems, achieve efficiency
by assigning an owner and a group to each file. Here
I'm displaying this information as the OS command would
show in the terminal. The owner, or user of the
file, is typically the creator of the file, and the
group might be faculty, or staff, or students or something
like that in a university setting. We have separate read,
write and execute bits for the owner or user, the
group, and then another set for everybody else. This gives
us a total of nine bits instead of 3 times
the number of users on the system. Permissions on directories
make the system even more complicated. The basic rule is that
reading affects your ability to see what's in the directory. Running
affects your ability to create, delete and rename files in the
directory. Both of these are intuitive if you think about
a directory as a file itself, containing the names of the
files and subject directories in it. Execute permissions are a little
more confusing, as they control whether you can pass through the
directory and access it's contents in ways other than just
manipulating the file names. For cases where more detailed permissions
are needed, access control lists are sometimes used on various
operating systems. These make it possible to create arbitrary row
values in our permissions matrix by granting permissions to individual
users or other groups defined in the file system. I
encourage you to explore some more on your own. Some
good places to start are provided in the instructor notes.